all right we got mcgregor and machine
gun kelly going at it this is
interesting yeah it is you know what i
find interesting about the conor
mcgregor machine gun kelly thing is they
had a little b for the vmas
seeing both of their pr teams try to be
the first one to start the story
yeah was fascinating so
machine gun kelly's team dropped it
first and this is what i read on people
i think and they put out the best thing
ever yeah conor attacked him after
machine gun kelly said he wasn't willing
to take a picture with connor yeah
which is i also read he wanted a picture
with megan fox and she said no and then
he got upset there's multiple varia
there's tons of stories out there right
but but the idea that like conor was a
fanboy and you were like nah nah i'm
good yeah that's a wild flex that's a
super flex
right connor's team is like nah that
didn't happen at all i forget exactly
what conor said they said it was
something like he didn't even know who
machine gun kelly was yeah and uh he
said uh
connor only fights fighters yeah he
really yeah yeah he doesn't fight uh
which isn't true he punched an old man
did he punch an old man he also threw
the water bottle on the train
he fought a bus
forklift
this guy will fight anything he could
fight a rhino that guy could take a
rhino
he would be a rhino hunter 100 he would
be a rhino hunter yeah he's got it in
him i'm going to put out a movie called
rhino hunter and it's going to be the
greatest movie despite all of you it's
the sequel to shark knight yeah and you
know what it's going to be directed by
not alex maybe that's what it's going to
be
i will have shark knight too we'll make
sure that rhino knight
is another thing you said is how they
not made a movie about this i thought
it's going to be so [ __ ] epic doug
you got to understand the expectations
the movie is coming the movie's coming
it will be direct four minutes long
it'll be directed by um [ __ ] steven
spielberg a short film it'll be written
by david fincher okay it'll be directed
by steven spielberg and it will be about
getting the animal animals
is he going to go from [ __ ] jurassic
park and dinosaurs to
taking cubs
it's actually in the ballpark that's
actually not a good argument he would do
it
guys not in the ballpark
he's going to do it you're going to ask
for a roll i'm going to let you
role that they [ __ ] used to project
do he's gonna play a
the rhinoceros just
just stand straight right there and
we'll let you poke a [ __ ] rhino and
then al al you don't get to do anything
when you say the cub story though i
thought it was genius i was so excited
dude the [ __ ] how did you steal a cup
and it would catch you seriously and
they would drop one
how do you steal a cub mother's gotta go
get food for the cup
so you just gotta sit there and wait you
gotta watch on a horse on a horse bro
the horse doesn't go as fast as the
tigers imagine holding four cats
what do you hold them in a basket
do you have a chariot do you have a
chariot
like this
yellow don't even know the levels of
reflection
y'all even know like
do y'all know that [ __ ] augustus
tried to come out with a chariot that
didn't have horses in the front and had
lions
but that's kind of that's not fire
that's fire you can't hurt cats that's
why they have that same thing yeah
they're gonna do that
you can you can't mark
you can't what are you augustus well you
said he tried did he succeed i feel in
that [ __ ]
i thought that was like
he tried he went for it dawg they was
trying to go for it back in the day i
just think you're led with a bad example
that's all right
right now [ __ ] you both i want you both
still haven't told us how rhinoceros
happened okay rhinoceros is uh it's not
your business
you can never understand i'm making the
movie both of you both of your scenes
are getting cut out fair enough yeah
we're going to feed out to the [ __ ]
rhinoceros
okay
the opposite is for sure you're getting
put in the rhinestones yeah yeah
okay what else what else
kelly thanks
i think it's a pr stunt
interesting i think connor's in on it or
not i think connor's in on it
i think
he can't be spiraling this badly i also
think machine gun kelly needs something
all the time
because none of us know his music
we're also old some know that's the
thing that i realized like i'm i'm with
you on that and i had that perspective
on him for a while but apparently he had
like a number one song he's like doing
this rock thing and it's basically like
younger girls
are into him yes that i believe the
music isn't for our generation we just
we just remember him obviously from the
eminem beef and before when he was a
rapper so we're like oh yeah so we
should be into your new music
but the reality is no was he big as a
rapper
he was always like very like connected
industry and had like a devout following
that's what i remember
he was known he had a couple of songs
did he manage them so he was always
connected yeah yeah yeah did he manage
him i think he's one of those guys
industry play and maybe i'm just old
quite possible i think he's one of those
guys that maybe he's an industry plant
the talent
isn't as big as the star power
of and part of that means you got to
keep the pr machine rolling we can there
is we know entertainers whose talent is
fine good maybe but somehow they're just
always in the tabloids kendrick can drop
an album whenever he wants and then
become the talk of the town there are
other people that need to constantly be
the talk of the town because they can't
necessarily go back to the album or to
the art to do yes now i guess the
pushback that he would have on that is
like i just have a number one [ __ ]
song like the the music is there yeah
and then a lot of people thought that he
got eminem on that
on in the battle like he didn't do bad
he didn't do badly i also was more more
so i was like oh eminem didn't really
bring it like he normally does as
opposed to yo machine gun kelly [ __ ]
ripped it which which that's a if you
show up to a fight and you don't fight
that girl
yeah i just he has a number one song
again to me you can get a number one
song just off of being famous and i
think he's a guy that is i'm gonna drive
the tabloids and that will drive the
career and that could very well be wrong
but to me
him and mitch and connor having a thing
that's headlines for connor which he
always thrives on and that's headlines
for mgk it looks like he's defending his
girl in a certain way it's like all
right well this is good for both of them
i i see that i can see that point i
think what's happening right now is that
conor is in like an incredibly sensitive
state
because
um
the thing that he has identified as
for the largest part of his life i would
say the majority of his life is being
able to [ __ ] people up yeah
and
he physically can't do it right now and
i think that that's
affecting the rest of his psyche as well
like you ever have a bad show yeah
right
and like there's insecurity that comes
yeah yeah everyone's your whole day
but you're also like looking to be
validated right like at any point in
time like if somebody messaged you yo i
just saw this clip it was [ __ ]
hilarious oh that feels really good now
i i'm gonna stop thinking these negative
thoughts that i have in my head about
how i'm bad and i'm like oh maybe people
find think that i'm pretty good but if
anything gets sent out that confirms
those negative thoughts that you have in
your real problem right
deeper exactly because that's what
you're feeling and then someone just
confirmed it so
imagine you're feeling insecure yeah and
i'm not saying this did happen but
imagine feeling insecure and then you
ask somebody for a picture right and
they say no
it's
if he's already feeling insecure like
he's losing his grasp of control in
terms of him being an elite fighter
him being the talk of the town and the
conversation with mma yeah and now this
other celebrity says i don't want to
take a picture with you that's your
biggest fear are you losing it is it
going away
or even he just was a little bit like he
bumped into him or whatever something
small could not be a picture but it
could be like he kind of bumped him and
shoved him off and he's like wait does
this [ __ ] civilian think just because
he's taller than me and i'm on one leg i
can't [ __ ] him up is that how far i've
fallen in this because perception yeah
is that how like not is that how much
i'm not a fighter people anymore is this
[ __ ]
cause because let's be honest the people
that [ __ ] people up like the people are
real beasts yeah at least the ones that
i've met in my life are the nicest
kindest individuals nothing to prove
nothing if you really feel like you
could [ __ ] anybody up you laugh when
somebody says something someone talks
some [ __ ] you're like all right buddy
yeah i've seen a lot of guys who could
really destroy like end people's lives
do this all right buddy just calm down
yeah because they know if it really gets
to the shits that's a wrap right and i
don't think that connor right now in his
state and understandably so is at the
level to be like all right buddy that's
cute yeah yeah i'd look at i think it's
a megan fox thing what do you mean like
the way that they were interacting like
i've watched this did you see the video
of the whole thing i only saw yeah
i watched the video
okay so like him like throwing the water
out and like getting held off but then i
saw an interview after where they asked
michigan and kelly and megan fox what
was going on and and like the whole
interview actually knows before the
altercation but their whole interaction
their whole energy is so bizarre so like
they're talking to the reporter and they
were like all right so megan like why'd
you wear this why'd you wear that outfit
and she was like oh because daddy said
he wanted me naked
and then they're like what and then
machine like kelly just stand in the
back like yeah and then like they're
making out on camera yeah then she's
really going for that [ __ ] yeah so
like they have this weird like daddy
complex thing where she's like yeah i
just do what daddy wants like that's the
whole situation isn't he younger than
her yes and i think that i could see i
could see connor being like oh i know
mega fox let me say what's up and then
she has to like report up to her daddy
and then they have a beef so that's what
i assumed it was interesting because i i
don't know i can't imagine conor knows
or cares who michelle kelly is but i
think he does characters i cannot
imagine conor wants a picture of machine
gun kelly i can see him wanting a
picture of mega fox i could see the the
megan fox thing even though he was there
with wifey yeah yeah but it's like let
me get a picture
and she's an iconic figure like yeah of
course he's probably seen her in [ __ ]
movies for the last you know decade yeah
so
she was famous before he was famous yeah
100 percent and what is she's so trash
she's calling him daddy
kelly yeah i just dropped her down like
a bunch of notches but i think what's
happening and i don't okay like the most
cynical version of me goes
all right the whole relationship is
constructed because you have these two
figures that people are kind of
interested in they're famous enough but
when their power is combined all the
something there it's really interesting
right they're interesting people to look
at megan is absolutely stunning like
she's one of the most beautiful
celebs out there she looks like a pinup
girl right like she looks like she's
tattooed on like navy people's arms back
in the day like world war ii tattoos
like stunning right and the machine gun
kelly is an interesting
thing to look at yeah he's wearing the
[ __ ] rhinestones on his face yeah
yeah like so now you combine them and
it's just you're multiplying right yeah
i'll stare at them he's also tall and
he's like six five yeah big kid right so
so now all of a sudden like you know
blogs are picking it up and everybody
loves a relationship right they're kind
of interesting and i think what happens
is the most cynical version is like they
plan this like they've planned past
relationships of famous people and then
they just are leaning into the things
that work ooh we're gonna do the
angelina jolie uh what was the other
guy's name billy bob thing where were
like super sexual and like into it like
a lot of the posts
on instagram are like oh my god what
happened on this table this weekend it's
got to be
you know it can't be shared or whatever
like that it's like it's this over
sharing of the sexualization of a
relationship and it almost seems like i
i see what you're doing here now the
most cynical version is the whole thing
is contrived
and and orchestrated and put together
the
more realistic take is
they like each other they started dating
the tabloids loved it and they realized
they were getting way more pressed for
their relationship maybe than the other
things going on in their lives her
movies his you know music etc so they're
like this is the movie this is the music
this is the clout let's lean into this
thing and we get mutual benefit megan
fox could look at as the hot girl again
she's in her 30s has had kids
people always thought she was hot but
maybe she wasn't the hot she forgot
about her yeah maybe there was like
other girls there were also margot
robbie's coming in looking pretty hot
about being a hot girl is there's always
another hot girl coming boom but now
everybody talking about her and you
don't think that her manager and then
got the google analytics in the black yo
people are searching your name ten
thousand times more when you and him are
making out in public
so and then they're doing the same with
him they're going you know people are
searching your name ten thousand times
more when you guys wear something crazy
invalidating some sexual boom
it kind of like reminds us of her and it
validates him
yeah it's like when everybody thought
that tom cruise was gay and all of a
sudden he got married twice yeah like
you know i mean like my man got married
and then married again he was like i am
not good doctor um doctor um
right like the dude was with the redhead
nicole kidman then penelope cruz i took
down two baddies right right and they
were like ah he's not gay he's just
weird
and then he was like i'm cool with that
as long as he'll call me weird i can
still be the leading man if i'm waiting
i still think he's good
enough for the midwest [ __ ]
were like right you could still do
mission impossible
i'll keep watching
mark brought up a point about this is an
mgk point mark brought up something and
i think it was an interesting question
he has ul and i don't get an answer is
how do you feel about white rappers who
transition into rock was that what you
asked yeah um
yeah because i always think it's a
little bit like it looks a little bit
like you just kind of used
rap and black people to elevate yourself
and then you transition to some more
mainstream sometimes it depends how they
do it so like uh post malone for example
he was a little
like a little sketchy with white iverson
cornrows yeah white robin basketball
phantom doing donuts and [ __ ] like that
and then quickly switched up and showed
kind of who he really is but like if you
uh what was that other guy the guy also
from i think texas with like big teeth
and [ __ ] like
no no no no another weird looking dude
oh bubba sparks
not even him
it's just [ __ ] uh there's a new guy
riffraff oh really oh yeah yeah like
that is somebody like if he switched
over to
like country or whatever i would be like
oh yeah you just use this for you just
use the culture just to get you on and
then you switched up because it looks so
performative so it kind of defense
depends how you how you do it we were
talking about this with derek poston oh
sorry i was thinking i kind of thought
that about mgk a little bit i was like
oh you used it and then you became it's
the kid rock [ __ ] i felt that about kid
rock is you were like this rap rock guy
and now you're like this kind of
kind of alt-right type like [ __ ] you
know country motherf and it's like kid
rockers kid rock yeah that's what you're
doing and then i don't get this i don't
think mgk is by any stretch gonna go all
right but i get a similar like you just
kind of use this and then transition
into no now you're a rock star but i
think people can have different genres
of music inside them like there are
rappers that change their [ __ ] up and
then they start singing a little bit
more and that's possible there are b
stars that start like rapping and then
they're like [ __ ] rock musicians that
go into [ __ ] country like darius
rucker and [ __ ] if you want to get into
music that hasn't that you're not
stepping on black people to get there
like there's no music yeah you know what
i mean like all music like is pioneer
even if he does rock it's still black
music yeah yeah so he's still [ __ ]
with the same genre yeah i it just feels
like i understand what you're saying
yeah you're looking at the most cynical
version of it
you